the level of Destruction here is is is
beyond imagination right over there you
can see that the rescue Air Force is
still continuing here a German rescue
team is trying to pull out another uh
another person who is alive out of the
the rubble so the families you can see
their families are also still there and
waiting just a little ago uh over there
where you can see the I will lifting
Machinery over there a 28 years old man
he has been rescued alive after 58 hours
under the rubble the rescue teams
managed to rescue him and then his
mother was waiting for him for hours his
owns his other relatives and when he has
been pulled out of the rubbles it was a
moment of Joy definitely there is a
shortage of waters food and lack of
electricity which is making the life
extreme really difficult here so today
the president erdogan has visited the
city of karaman maharash here as it was
the epicenter of the disaster and he has
visited a tent city that was set up by
the authorities hours after the the
earthquake and now it is the home for
thousands of people erdogan promised for
reconstruction for more for housing for
those who survived but as I said here as
the time is passing the hopes are fading